volà le petit canard texte de marie
paule leur est l'illustration
pierre-henri champeau souraya édition
coco tu vois ce petit canard ni
s'appelle paulin un jouet rencontra un
âne et lui dit coin coin coin pâte à
quoi un choix un choix
l'anme fion lutte ouanna le dos en
braille ont complètement fou ce canard
il s'éloigna rapidement pour bouter
tranquillement l'herbe verte des prêts
quinqua pollet poursuivi son chemin ça
lui a poliment un gros cochon et lui
demanda coincoin pata coin un choix un
choix
le cochon se mettent à grogner
complètement zinzin ce canard là il
remue à sa queue en tire bouchon et
surtout anna sans se soucier du pauvre
petit canard décourager le coeur gros
paulin avant ça longtemps sans savoir où
aller loin bien loin
il a perçu la maison de madame la poule
ils se dépêcha d'y arriver devant la
porte d'entrée le répéta coin coin coin
un pata coin et soit un joint la merde
pour la folle et à plat tous ces
poussins ferma la porte à clé et criant
êtes ont vite monsieur le renard de mal
à déguiser en canard voyais au voleur
assassin
tu n'auras pas les poussins elle vole a
furieusement vers le tuyau d'arrosage et
lança un jet d'eau glacée sur le triste
petit canard jusqu'à le faire basculer
dans le fossé plein de croo temps
après bien des efforts il réussit à se
relever
devant lui une mare la cachette
d'étrangeté tard à peine commencée t-il
à se dégoter que tout à coup sûr des
nénuphars de minuscule grenouille se
mirent à danser en se moquant de lui
pauvre paulin deux grosses larmes colère
sur ces vous déjà mouillé
à ce moment-là passama nous une très
gentil grand-mère à la même magique
toujours à la recherche de petits
malheureux en voyant le triste petit
canard elle s'empressa de le prendre
délicatement dans sa douce main pour le
consoler le lave et le sécher le
caresser paulin de marmonner coin coin
coin pata coin choix un choix
quelle chance manou connaît le langage
des canards 1 2 mois est de moi se plier
le petit paul un jeu super aux deux jeux
ne peut pas rattraper la voiture bleue
de ma petite amie son coussin séraphin
m'acheter dans un tournant en pleine
campagne
son père n'a rien vu sa mère rien
entendu emma pauline rien aperçu mano de
sursauter pauline elle posa le petit
canard sur un lit de mousse avant de lui
montrer la photo collée à l'intérieur du
médaillon d'or suspendu à son cou en
reconnaissant pauline le petit coin coin
rosstat immobile les yeux tout ronds
sans attendre de questions manouche
entonna gaiement pauline ce soit tu la
verras chez sa grand-mère des bois qui
est juste devant toi tu peux ce t2 soit
elle t'emportera tu dormiras blotti dans
ses petits bras sur un grand lit de soi
paula et manos mirta pirouetter
à tourbillonner à s'égosiller devant les
lapins tout étonné au coucher du soleil
c'est en se dandinant joyeusement que
paula s'en alla vers la maison du
bonheur
accompagné de mc do la baby de son coeur
imagine la joie de pauline et celle de
paul heures en se retrouvant mais aussi
la honte de séraphin en écoutant la
chanson qui le grund sévèrement le petit
coin tulle embêtera points tous les
matins tu l'emmènera au bain dans la
forêt de sapins
même si c'est loin bien loin pauline est
resté quelques jours chez manon avec
pauline et séraphin
tous les matins il va au bain dans la
forêt des sapins séraphin l'accompagnent
même si c'est loin très loin
pas question de faire le vilain
maintenant il prend bien soin du petit
coin coin dans le grand bassin
paulin s'amuse comme un diablotin pas
plier le reggae est pas tape la cha cha
cha tête en haut le tango tête en bas la
polka dès son retour à la maison de
manou paulin rejoint pauline et la fête
recommence jeux de ballons sur le gazon
jeu de cache cache sous les bâches jeu
de marelle sous la tonnelle chaque soir
après le souper paul ince blottie contre
pauline séraphin s'enfonce dans un
oreiller de plumes ils écoutent
attentivement les belles histoires que
l'on raconte manu